elles sont douze d'allonnes de
l'académie de la plaine des cafres a
présenté officiellement devant le grand
public leurs projets collectifs
un court métrage de dix minutes qui
traite de l'exclusion des personnes sans
domicile fixe au niveau de ce projet
donc le jeune femme de la promotion 5
elle avait souhaité donc se centrer sur
la thématique des personnes sans
domicile fixe pour cela donc elles ont
fait différent phasage est long
étaient donc à la découverte de ce
public elles ont travaillé que l'appât
rouge agent fait des marottes et puis au
fur et à mesure elles ont souhaité faire
un court métrage pour sensibiliser les
personnes sur ce public
sdf écrit réalisé et interprété par ces
jeunes filles
ce court métrage est une première riche
en expérience alors le fait d'incarner
un personnage est de ceux-là l'archi à
travers le personnage c'était bien ben
déjà beaucoup plus de confiance en soi
une part de ma timidité s'est envolé
donc voila voila j'ai eu un rôle très
important c'était la directrice
du magasin donc c'était un rôle très
important et difficile au début
d'accepter de jeu ce rôle mais avec la
motivation ça s'est bien passé j'ai bien
aimé ben moi je joue la sdf
madame paule à ben
c'est un peu d air un peu folle gentil
attentionné et voilà c'est d'allonnes
ont été accompagnés par deux
professionnels de l'audiovisuel pour
concrétiser ce court métrage intitulé
juge pas ben sdf une projection salué
par les spectateurs
après la sensibilisation contre la
violence conjugale
la prévention routière c'est l'exclusion
des sdf qui marque l'engagement de l'
académie des dalons on devient pas sdf
comme ça donc il ya du avoir sûrement un
chacun son chemin de vie et un moment
donné on tombe on sait pas comment il le
fait d'être des deux dates dans ce crime
est d'avoir fait ce crime
c'est justement peut-être aussi le
donner
le fait de passer par cette académie
peuvent se remettre en question et se
dire que tout n'est pas perdu l'aide à
solidarité le soutien par un sourire ou
par agreste
tout est important et ça empêche
stéphane et jean de de sombrer donc je
pense que la réinsertion sociale que la
redynamisation de ces jeunes qui sont ce
soir en données trouvées en difficulté
sur le plan familial social
professionnel
c'est un très bon un très bon projet